all right
so this is
your trainee stance
we call it a neutral bow
okay
mid-foot vector so my weight is on the
mid foot vector
okay
i got rid of that
concaveness in the lower back
and now i'm going to move
move on my
own ground vector
so the pattern is
back ground vector around it
from the back
onto the front ground vector
back around
you're doing
figure eight
with your weight
but you can't go
too far do you see
it's going around this foot back
this
is not my waist
so i do my strikes
again it's a makiwara it's not a board
to break
so
[Music]
don't try to break the board
try to do
the weight shifting
boom so the outward hand sword is not
going to be
on that one
[Music]
and get your elbows close okay
open and close your rotator cuff while
your hand
and form your weapons don't get lazy
form your weapon form your weapon
okay so elbows close to your body
and down not out
so you can feel
that's where that one is
and feel
boom
it's right after the other one okay so
it's on the back foot
front foot
back foot
okay
so
if he's
if he's just mass resistance
then
that's what i'm doing
[Music]
you're going to hit targets
when you hit the other one
got it so you're not going to do
well i'm not trying to break the maki
water board
my weight is in the strikes
okay so i'm not
somebody like
there's no weight shifting
you're leaving your weight here so
i'm not trying to use my arms i'm trying
to
let my arms
be moved
okay
try it
uh
so
now now
i'm going to uh
give me some money
that's what he's trying to do and i'm
going to do
the strike movements
[Music]
did you see the movement
is this movement
but my hands are here
okay got it okay try okay so i'm i'm not
doing anything with my hands i'm not
trying to do anything i'm not trying to
uh
he's the one pushing my hands to see and
he's pushing my hands and my hand
there there is loose over there do you
get it so as as my weight shifts it'll
he's pushed it
okay i wouldn't keep it here you can see
where that that's gonna put it on my
heel okay so i'm not trying to do
something with my hand that was the
whole point
um so don't do anything with your hands
just move your body move your body on
that
putter
okay
uh
secondly
if you
brace and you push you're gonna get
pulled because
you sent him out he's holding on he's
getting ready to push back in
um
you have to look for that that wasn't it
either and then also
sometimes when you were bracing you went
on and then you shut it off and you're
gonna get pulled again so there's no off
you're just doing the same drill the
reason there's no op is even when it's
just me my weight is on that midfoot
pattern so
uh i'm just keeping that powder
okay try the reason i had him pushing is
because when you hit a target it is
it is not moving in the direction that
i'm going
uh
even if even if i had it going backwards
uh and i'm hitting him that way i'm
still hitting through him so
there's much of his energy is not
traveling in the same direction that i'm
going okay and so his energy is coming
towards me in the drill okay and the
little pull thing you don't need to you
don't pull in the drill because
he is just uh
trying to do that other thing which
is going to be a
more of a stepping stone to this truck
okay
um the pool will happen automatically so
it'll it'll test your ikea and ikea
always is like that even in the
techniques it comes up as a result of
cooking okay
so you don't have to
do it you don't want to do it okay you
want to keep the on
so okay has to stay on going up
all right so um i'm not going to hit him
and i'm going to disperse the energy of
the strike
um we will work on the
outward hand sword okay
so when i say disperse it i'm gonna make
my whole my forearm hit as opposed to
just the hand which would be how you hit
on the target okay uh and you can see
okay that's the energy there so i'm just
going to
get
okay
at this point there's usually two
beginner mistakes that you want to do
because you prioritize moving him you
see so you're like sensei i'm gonna
do my own okay and so you you start
to push
that's not a strike how are you starting
to hit from kitchen
you see that
two things is
um yeah your drills your drills might
your your cultivation drills might
prolong
uh this whole process
but you've got to be able to uh
shorten the amount of time that it takes
to do that okay so you it's going to be
lengthened for cultivating reasons but
you're not going to get anywhere if you
can't do the same process oh like spark
from the stone okay
um and two
um
when you turn your waist you go to hip
rotation
you you actually dismantle the the
internal organization
um you if you think of it like i get
expanded with his energy that's coming
into me
uh so imagine like a balloon and now
you're gonna turn the two hands like
because you're going to make a wiener
dog out of balloons do you get it and
it's not very strong you don't want to
uh twist the balloon you're gonna
decompress so to speak okay
um so
as i as i'm doing this
it's it's a same process boom but quick
quick
[Music]
okay try it again so again i'm gonna
disperse the inward hand sword it's a
little awkward
uh it's hard to fit in there so you see
on the drill i'm kind of off center yeah
i'm not fighting him he's just
resistance okay
uh and i like using the body as
resistance because there's nothing that
quite feels like the body
um
the machiwara that's why it's flexible
because it there's give and take
not like a board or something like that
okay
and all those little give and takes and
fluids and joints and points of
articulation just body it all creates
different angles of different things i
gotta address and send down through me
to the ground okay
uh
so i still have to disperse the energy
because i don't want to
cause any damage on him so i'm going to
disperse the energy okay
i'm here and i'm going to so i have to
do the same
powder
you this is just general rule and i
didn't mention it because it's so
general you don't hit the surface
you don't hit the surface you you're
hitting somewhere back here okay and so
in your focal point
it's back here got it
don't don't don't kiss the surface so my
teacher used to say don't don't knock
the oranges off
off the tree take it and smash it into
the trunk okay so that's the difference
so you're not you're not here
and you're trying to do that you see
you're trying to get back here well some
of you are
touching here and then pushing back
there and that's not it okay so my hand
is quick
you could i would pay attention to how
fast the hand is moving through space
okay when you push it doesn't move very
quickly okay
oh my hand is pretty quick
and it's going through him
same pattern it's the same pattern but
shrunk down smaller okay more internal
wow
okay try it again
okay so we're going to put that stripe
this side is the hand of the kokujo okay
so you're going to you're going to yield
there's the strike right there
okay so this i bring that target
in my pattern
it'll be about there
that's where my pattern comes in
hits
okay
so
up the center line
turn
but the weight pattern is the same boom
right there
okay so yield
boom
once you're here you can see
you can see you you have the two
but i'm
the two contact points in the adhesion
but this is boom deep
and
here
don't keep your elbow up
don't open yourself up
it's very tight quack
fine
it's gonna be okay
i i'm kind of i definitely am pulling
the strike
um but uke takes
a lot of the energy off because he's
doing your chemi so he has to reconcile
the young energy with the yin energy if
he stays following the adhesion
he will move his target
the neck
in correspondence with the stripe okay
if you're getting killed on the neck
it's okay
let's go
keep going sean
push
margaret you're on the outside
you're on the outside you want to be on
the inside
you're on the outside
[Music]
so i'm not getting out of the way and
hitting you there
this is very easy to block
okay so
you're pushing
i turn inside
hey
okay
remember
striking's in the phone booth
right if i
if i could
[Music]
move this far
i would have in the first place okay
so
we're we started talking
but what i'm doing
is i'm close
okay well my elbow is anchored right
here whoa okay
no not out here like that
striking is tight striking is a much
tighter than you think okay
hey
but i'm not going to let him grab me
he'll do the same thing
inside
he it's a shoulder temp move
make sure your elbow is coming in that's
where your power is your elbow power
don't leave your elbow out
also free the uh ball and socket joint
so you'll have to turn your palm out
just like when you throw a ball that has
to turn out if you want to look very
uncoordinated don't turn it out same
thing here you look very uncoordinated
as it's moving out in
[Music]
okay
again
i'm pulling it
but he's the one that's responsible for
it
okay here we go
okay uh so somebody looked at me all
weird where uh
i said you can't enter and then tencon
okay
well you should have just done what i
was doing
okay
but
you're gonna walk into that other strike
you see here boom
so you don't do that you're coming up
[Music]
so he could throw the other stripe
you still have the center line okay
you're not going to move yourself over
coming up
everything's happening inside
okay so
uh
we'll go to
yoko man now okay and again don't throw
him out there
excuse me
he's gonna try to
boom
got it
well you followed the same way
the same way you do what shomonucci so
when the shomonucci is going up
that's where i harmonize okay
so the strike is going up that's where i
harmonize
harmonize and then yield to it inside of
it
do not
block it that's not aikido
inside
strike
i'm gonna give you one a little one okay
because it looks like i'm pushing
[Music]
okay try it
there's a sequence of operations so as
as he goes you can go a little quicker
right
that that's the striking part that does
happen okay
okay that is happening got it
so but if you pay attention
after you hit
now you use those two hands in your
adhesion
to do the cookie nugget okay
so
you're not just going
cookie nugget
do you see that
but nor are you just going boom
so you're going to hit when there's a
percussiveness there
that then goes
into
radiation do you see that
i'll try to accentuate it a little bit
more
[Music]
so i don't want to just be standing here
there's no cookie nugget now
oh
finish down here
not out of here disconnected
okay
good
keep going
nope
that's a block you gotta have more
chemistry
follow going up throw the same
there you go
right you're on the insteps fix your
feet fix your feet nope try it again be
ready don't be off you can listen to me
and be ready
good again
switch rolls
nope you're late you're late kimusubi
catch it coming up be ready
you're striking the same way tristan
you're not doing a strike you're doing a
shoulder grab
you're doing the same strike you were
doing as
nagia go
bring your elbow in come on
bring your elbow in
switch your kiss alright on both sides
now
[Music]
you're a little late catch the kimusubi
little knight switch rolls
straighten your back don't punch